[Música]
bienvenidos a ello soy de france 24
britney spears es libre el 12 de
noviembre del 2021 quedó marcado como el
día en que finalizó la tutela legales
sobre su persona y su patrimonio tras
más de 13 años vamos a analizar su caso
y porque el movimiento 'free britney
lejos de ser una frivolidad se convirtió
en una cuestión de derechos humanos pero
primero recordemos los acontecimientos
que emanciparon a la cantante
a partir de hoy la tutela de la persona
y el patrimonio de britney spears se
termina por la presente
la jueza brindé ipen y le devolvió a
britney spears el control de su vida a
sus 39 años de edad tras 13 años de
tutela sobre su fortuna y sobre su
persona la que es una de las mujeres más
poderosos del mundo puede de nuevo hacer
uso de sus bienes y de sus derechos de
ciudadanía
[Aplausos]
[Música]
dios mío amo tanto a mis fans que es una
locura creo que voy a llorar el resto
del día el mejor día de mi vida alabado
sea el señor puedo obtener un amén
afuera de la corte sus seguidores y
miembros del movimiento 'free brindis
celebraron eufóricos
[Aplausos]
la tutela fue establecida en 2008 y
supervisada por su padre james spears
tras un colapso de salud mental que
obligó a la cantante a internarse varias
veces en tratamientos no revelados y que
llevó a la pérdida de custodia de sus
dos hijos por años fue considerada
legalmente incapaz para tomar sus
propias decisiones y en un estado de
salud mental demasiado delicado para
recibir altas dosis de estrés para
cuidarse o cuidar de otros sin embargo
fue impulsada por su tutor para
continuar trabajando y facturar miles de
millones de dólares con conciertos y
producciones musicales entre otras
actividades de su marca personal en
repetidas ocasiones a lo largo de una
década britney solicitó recuperar su
autonomía sin éxito y finalmente en 2021
en una revisión de su caso denunció usos
de su padre y de su equipo legal
incluyendo vigilancia de vídeo en su
habitación y que lo obligaron a drogarse
y a planificar entre otros vejámenes
hasta que el 12 de noviembre pasado
recobró su libertad
durante la audiencia definitiva incluso
lo harían white la abogada de jodi
montgomery a quien se le había confiado
la supervisión de la vida personal
después dijo que no hay ninguna razón
por la que esta terminación no pueda
ocurrir y la señora spears no pueda
vivir una vida segura feliz y plena al
final de la cita se pronunció el abogado
de spears matthew rosengart
ella destaca lo que le sucedió y según
su propio testimonio del 23 de junio y
luego el 14 de julio el abuso que sufría
en relación con su padre quien dirigía
esta tutela estoy muy orgulloso de ella
porque no sólo arrojó luz sobre esta
tutela sino que también arrojó luz sobre
las tutelas de california a nueva york y
california a aprobar una legislación
para tratar de garantizar que las
tutelas como éstas que fueron
corrompidas por su padre no vuelvan a
ocurrir
leyendo el testimonio de britney
resolver el congreso de eeuu que analiza
la ley sobre el tema con miras a aprobar
una legislación para garantizar que no
se abuse de las personas
si esto le pasó a britney le puede pasar
a cualquiera por eso quiero agradecer
abrimos el abogado dijo también que se
estableció una red de seguridad para
ayudarla a volver a la vida normal
para conversar sobre el desenlace del
caso conocido como free pretty está en
ellas hoy christina a near abogada de la
universidad de los andes y candidata a
máster en justicia y tutela de los
derechos christina bienvenida gracias y
las tutelas se imponen en general a
personas en coma o con enfermedades
mentales graves perdura durante el
tiempo que esta medida o premio spears
ella lanzó cuatro álbumes realizó una
residencia millonaria en las vegas' por
cuatro años con 140 millones de dólares
de ganancias lanzó productos de moda y
además también fue jurado del factor x
hubo coherencia en esa tutela
bueno muchísimas gracias angela y a la
audiencia que nos ha acompañado hoy es
que este caso es muy muy extraño
digamos por la manera en que se está
manejando las interdicciones tú te las
guardas como como les quieran decir en
eeuu generalmente este tipo de
procedimientos legales se hace para
técnicamente proteger el patrimonio de
la vida de personas que tienen
complicaciones en temas como de
discapacidad ya sea discapacidades
físicas discapacidades psicosociales
discapacidades e intelectuales o que por
la edad van perdiendo un poco el el
sentido de
el manejo de sus bienes de su vida y que
por eso digamos que necesitan algún tipo
de apoyo
generalmente
digamos que las personas que tienen
alguna enfermedad degenerativa o que
como ya dije tienen tal vez algún
trastorno psicosocial depresión severa o
síndrome de dawn generalmente son
personas que
terminan siendo sujetos de este tipo de
guardas en el caso de eeuu se está
viendo no solo con el caso de britney
hay más casos digamos que es también
conocido el caso de amanda bynes que es
otra actriz que en este momento está
interpreta que son sobre todo mujeres
que a la luz pública tienen ciertos
problemas de abuso de drogas de
ludopatía de problemas de digamos que
actitudinales severos que afectan su
imagen entonces digamos que sus familias
o sus personas cercanas terminan
estableciendo este tipo de guardas sobre
todo pues para manejar el tema de su
imagen personal pero técnicamente la
figura de la interdicción aplicada para
personas que generalmente como lo
concibe la sociedad no están listas para
participar en la sociedad como personas
que entre comillas serían normales que
no pueden trabajar que no
e
y tener cierta comunicación con las
personas de forma digamos que
socialmente aceptada entonces digamos
que el caso de britney el caso de estas
otras actrices que terminan siendo
digamos que víctimas entre comillas de
esta figura de la tutela en la
interdicción es muy extraño porque si
técnicamente como tú lo dices no
deberían estar trabajando pero vinnie
está de gira está teniendo un montón de
ganancias batur es pero entonces
por este caso pues todavía hay mucho que
decir en su opinión podría haber aquí
una violación de derechos humanos
pues
personalmente creo que sí desde el
momento en que se establece la
interdicción el tema de la interdicción
es muy complicado principalmente porque
limita los derechos de las personas con
discapacidad tengan una discapacidad
leve media o grave entendiéndose eso
como sea digamos que no soy experta en
esos temas pero
digamos que estas figuras limitan
muchísimo la autonomía de las personas
las personas terminan siendo sujetas de
otra persona que toma todas sus
decisiones no sólo en materia
patrimonial que digamos es como lo que
más escucha de las personas que están en
envueltas en este tipo de guardias que
no pueden manejar su dinero que digamos
son
ludópatas entonces van a despilfarrar el
patrimonio familiar sino que también
pueden tener acceso a ciertos
tratamientos médicos de forma autónoma
no
en este caso cristina fueron 13 años de
audiencia sé qué fue lo que hizo la
diferencia en el 2021 porque logro
britney spears de que se le escuchara y
sobre todo que se atendiera su pedido de
que ya no fuera más su papá de su tutor
y finalmente de que se levantará la
tutela claro el asunto empieza en 2021
sino que en realidad empieza un poco en
2019 primi tenía un abogado en
los procesos de tutela judicial
de interdicción en eeuu la persona que
está interdicta tiene derecho a contar
con un abogado para para que revise
digamos que la persona que está haciendo
curadora de ella pues esté manejando
bien sus finanzas o los temas que
digamos que los que esté encargado
ese abogado digamos que parece que no
estaba haciendo una muy buena gestión y
en 2019 se empiezan a filtrar unos
audios de ella en audiencias sobre la
gestión que está teniendo su papá como
curador entonces si no hubiera sido por
esa filtración porque el proceso es
técnicamente es privado es un proceso de
jurisdicción voluntaria en el que
digamos que la persona interesada que no
es la persona a la que van a interdictar
sino el papá un amigo
digamos que solicita ante el juez que
digamos que esta persona la inter dicte
es un proceso súper privado entonces si
no hubiera sido por estas filtraciones
realmente el caso no hubiera avanzado
como avanzó y además de eso quisiera
preguntarle por otra cosa perdón pero es
que tenemos que abarcar muchos temas el
movimiento de free britney es calificado
por quienes no lo conocen como un chiste
en muchos casos y como un tema de
fanaticada porque no lo es porque free
britney sí fue fundamental para dar luz
a un caso de pérdida de derechos de una
mujer
pues yo diría que principalmente este
movimiento o en esta movilización social
pone en el foco un problema de derechos
humanos que lleva discutiéndose
desde hace muchísimos años pero digamos
que en materia de derechos humanos de
sistema universal de derechos humanos
desde 2006 en 2006 la onu saca
una convención de derechos de personas
con discapacidad en la que establece que
estos mecanismos de interdicción son
super invasivos a la autonomía de las
personas y que tienen que cambiarse
estos mecanismos por otros que impliquen
tal vez una toma de decisiones con
apoyos que la persona que tiene alguna
discapacidad o que es una persona adulta
mayor con algún tipo de problema
degenerativo cuente con apoyos pero no
con una figura tan invasiva como es la
interdicción como digamos lo vemos con
el caso de britney sobre todo el caso
del indio es muy importante porque a
partir de su testimonio se ven muchas de
las problemáticas que implican estos
problemas de interdicción no solo en el
manejo patrimonial sino también digamos
en el manejo de derechos sexuales y
reproductivos brindisi tenía un planté
intrauterino que es el día con un método
anticonceptivo que ella misma no
consentía esto es un nivel de violencia
obstétrica increíble y que sufren
muchísimas mujeres actualmente no sólo
en eeuu sino también en el resto del
mundo sobre todo en latinoamérica donde
esta práctica de la interdicción sigue
estando vigente bueno christina pues ya
nos quedamos sin tiempo pero gracias a
usted por el análisis y la aclaración y
con este punto que nos dice de cómo
muchas mujeres en el mundo pueden
sufrirlo pues quiero cerrar con algo que
dijo su abogado y es que si esto le
puede pasar a britney spears una de las
mujeres más famosas y poderosas del
mundo le puede pasar a cualquiera y este
es un espejo enorme de la vulnerabilidad
de los derechos de las mujeres y de la
dominancia de masculinidad es tóxicas
gracias a ustedes por estar en ellas hoy
y nos vemos próximamente
[Música]